du bist ja wie kindersitze aber was ist
was was denkst du eigentlich wer hat
frau merkel uns bislang so durch die
krise durch navigieren was denkst du
wenn es in einem jahr nicht mehr da ist
ich glaube dass wir dadurch auch
mitgemacht seien entweder zu haben sein
egal wie die wahl auf ich bleibe haben
nicht gehen ich habe ihnen werden
aufruhr seien weiblich märz ist die
suche nach einer endlagerstätte grabmal
deswegen könnten ärzte mal gemeinsam
entsorger weil er ist auch den alten
[Musik]
zustand der spd
ja wie ist sind schon amt endlager
vorbei hier sind schon beerdigt das ist
leider ziemlich wohl auch mutig dann als
schon zu sagen ich will kanzler werden
das gespann oder auch längst realität
nicht den anstand bei der spd keine
rolle mehr
aber mit dem album und er saß ja es geht
die sage ich ja immer so schön er sich
sowieso ein bisschen so aus als wenn er
der ja der plan heißt nicht mehr kommt
mit der letzten ölung dieser aston villa
setzte dabei und dann ist bald vorbei
bei der spd noch ein paar tagen ich mach
ball zu bleiben
[Musik]